how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things relating to the MCU and
today we have some awesome news as we
have our first leaked photos from the
set of the Loki series coming to Disney
Plus that shows us some new characters
there have been a lot of rumors flying
around about the Loki series and now we
have some official proof to back them up
including of course pictures of Tom
Hiddleston himself Owen Wilson and what
looks to be the TVA and a new character
that could be enchantress or lady Loki
so I'll show and go over all of these
photos and breakdown what they mean for
the Loki series coming to Disney Plus if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up-to-date with MCU news and I'm still
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 all you
have to do to enter is subscribe with
notifications turned on like the video
and comment down below about the video
so the first photos that we have here
are of Tom Hiddleston of course as Loki
and Owen Wilson presumably as justice
piece who was the leader of the TVA now
in the Loki teaser that we got that
Marvel released during the Superbowl we
saw Loki in a somewhat of a prison
uniform that said TVA on it which stands
for the time variance Authority they are
responsible for keeping timelines in
order so if another timeline another
reality or somebody in another timeline
and reality starts to threaten others
they eliminate them and one of the
theories that we had was that Loki is
going to be recruited by them forcibly
mind you to help them stop somebody
probably King we've had some reports
from this from several insiders
including Mikey Sutton who said that
King is going to come first before
Galactus and Doctor Doom and as we look
at these photos here this is apparently
true because it does look like Loki and
justice peace and the TVA
are working together Loki is not in a
uniform in fact it looks like he's in
work clothes you see him in Owen
Wilson's Justice piece next to him and
the soldiers of the TVA around them it
definitely looks like they're on a
mission and it definitely looks like
Loki is officially helping the TVA and
if you look at the jacket that Loki is
wearing he seemingly has the same badge
on it that everybody else has the badge
is really hard to make out but we
assumed that it's some sort of a symbol
for the TVA and then we have some leaked
photos of who we believe to be
Enchantress enchantress is somebody
has been reported to be in the Loki
series for a pretty long time now now
this could also be a female version of
Loki however she does have blonde hair
in this and enchantress does have blonde
hair as well now if we take a look at
her it does look like she is wearing a
very similar suit to Loki it looks just
like a suit from thor ragnarok it's
green and it even has that gold neck
band that is right there above the chest
so a lot of people do think that this is
a female version of Loki due to the
similarities in their costumes however
the enchantress that has been reported
to appear in the show is Silvie lustin
and this version of enchantress Loki
actually creates and gives her mystic
powers much like his own so since Loki
creates her it would make sense that he
sort of dresses her like he does and she
would probably want to be dressed as him
anyways now in one of these photos she
is talking to one of the members of the
TVA it is possible that they're going to
change up the backstory just a little
bit Loki could meet her while he's
working for the TVA because she could be
a member as well in this photo here it
does seem like she's wearing very
similar outfit to this member of the TVA
so it's possible that she's just a
normal person working for the time
variant authority and then Loki picks
her to become enchantress and gives her
powers because we know Loki he's not
going to be working for the TVA for that
long and he's probably only working for
them to get some sort of gain for
himself but along the way he could meet
a woman who could be his romantic
interest of the film and he could turn
her into enchantress and of course there
is a possibility that it could be the
female version of Loki and perhaps
they're going to give her a black wig
later on but that's usually not how it
works you don't film scenes without a
wig on and even if this is in between
sees the wigs that are designed for TV
stars and movie actresses they don't
really come off that easily so she
wouldn't be taking it off in between
sets and not to mention today we had a
report from discussing a film that said
you can find Kaylee Fleming listed as a
young Sylvie aka enchantress on IMDB Pro
now I am DB Pro is very different than
regular IMDB anyone can go in and edit
IMDB and put whatever they want they can
go and put Hugh Jackman is in Avengers
end game we saw that before but IMDB Pro
is not like that only verified people
can make edits so it listing it young
Sylvie is most likely very true and this
is probably in
interests that we see in this leaked
photo and those are our first leaked
photos from the set of the Loki series
coming to Disney Plus let me know what
you think about these in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe but notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the Loki series
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof